みなさんこんにちは･･･
太りましたぁ！
思ったより太りましたァ！
僕体重がですね、
昔ずっと65kgをキープしてたんですけども
いつからだろう･･･
去年かな！？
去年からナゼか体重が異常に増えてしまって！
分かんない、年齢のせいなのかな？
分かんないんですけど
何かすごい最近体重が落ちないと言うか
一回すごいダイエットしたじゃないですか
六十何kgまで落ちたんですけど
最近ちょっとまたｸﾞｸﾞｸﾞｸﾞｯって
上がってきて
気付いたらもう、
70kgくらいをずっとキープしてるんすよ
ちょっと乗ってみましょう！
え、ヤバあ！！でっぶぅ！！！
＜悲しい音楽＞♪ﾀﾗ-ﾝ　ﾀﾀﾀｰﾝﾀﾝ
ﾀﾗﾗｰﾝ　ﾀﾀﾀﾀｰﾝ
いや本当にちょっとマジで
せめて65kgキープでいたい。
（悪めの滑舌で）65kgくらいが何か
すごいちょうどいいスリム感だったんで
ちょっとね、5kgくらい痩せたいと思います！
若干肉が付いてきちゃってるかなって
気もするんで、
それだけは何とかこう･･･
減らしていきたいなと思っております。（変なポーズ）
あの普通に走っても
まぁ痩せるっちゃあ痩せるんですけども
それだと、効率が悪い！！
そういう時にこう、汗をかいて
身体の毒素とかを排出するために、
「サウナスーツ」皆さん、（変なポーズ２回目）
使ったことありますでしょうか。
はい、こちらですねぇ
汗の量が･･･
･･･あれこれ、こんな汗かくの！？（焦）
これを着ると多分結構汗が出るんだと思います。
完全にダイエット用のサウナスーツですねぇ。
これぇ、
重ね着したら効果が倍になるんじゃね？
ってことで、8枚準備しました。
これ一個着る8倍の効果があるという事で
普通の8倍の汗がかけるんじゃないかなと
思いまして、
なんか、短距離でもすごい痩せるんじゃね？
っていう天才的発想に陥った訳ですぉ！
着ていきます！！！
うわあああ！！
おぉおぉおぉ･･･
なるほどなるほど
こういう感じか！
全然何か、汗は出そうですけど
やっぱ1枚だと弱いっすね。
もっと重ねてみましょぅ！
＜やる気MAXモードなBGM＞
ｳｨｳ…
ﾊｧ…
はい、というわけでいかがでしょうか？
一応今サウナスーツ8枚着ております
クルシイ！！ヤバイ！！！
自分の肌が触れナイ（ドラゲナイ的な）！！
ちと衝撃的にスゴイ暑いんですけど、
こうすることによってー、
今の僕は
ちょっとした運動をするだけでも
普通に動く、8倍の
何かが消費されています
アッハッハ☆
ｽﾊﾞﾗｼｲ…☆
100ｍ走ると、800ｍ走ったくらいの
何かが消費されるんで
きっと僕が軽い運動をして
その終わった後に体重を量ると、
けぇっこー 体重減ってるんじゃねえかなって思いまして
ちょっと軽く運動してきます！
では行こう！！☆
はい、というわけで外に来ました！！
えーと、今これ見てもらったら分かるんですけど
結構直線なんですよね
まだどれくらい走って
どれくらいの影響が出るのかも分からないので
とりあえず走ってみようと思います！！
じゃ、いってきやす☆
＜ひたすらに車と風の音＆陽気なBGM＞
やべ、でも思ったほどきつくないぞこれ。
イケる気しかしねえぜ☆
＜陽気なBGM＞
･･･スゴイきつい！
＜いつものやつぅぅぅ＆風の音＞
ヤバイヤバイヤバイ！！！
（上がった息）
ちょっと待って下さい･･･
ヤバすぎる！
（上がり過ぎた息）
大体100ｍくらい走ったんですけど
何か･･･
心臓が痛いっす･･･
何でだ！？
そんな、なんか運動不足ってわけでも
ないと思うんですけど･･･
スゴイ苦しいっす、むちゃくちゃ。
んじゃ、折り返し行ってきます。
（上がった息＆いつものぉぉぉ♪）
ｳｩｩﾛｫｴｪｪｯﾎｯﾎ!!!!!（ヤバい咳）
（上がった息＆だからいつものって。）
カメラマン）頑張ってください！
（上がった息）
ちょっとまって･･･！ちょっと待って･･･
（上がった息＆いーつーもーのーって！）
･･･何か汗、汗の前に生き物的な危機を感じますね･･･
でもまだ汗はかいてないよね･･･？
ちょと、もうちょっと頑張ってみます
（上がった息＆わかって。）
やぁばい、キツイ、もう無理！！
もう走れない、走れない
ちょっと歩かせてください
ちょっとまって･･･
＜悲しいBGM＞
え待って、本当にすごい。
これ多分走っちゃダメですねぇ。
走るのも心臓の負荷が･･･
ちょっと走ってるだけでも
多分全力疾走の感覚に陥るんだと思います
ちょっとまって、想像以上だなあ･･･
＜ノロマなBGM？＞
ちょっとまって、ちょっとまって。
（上がる息）
待ってヤバすぎる！！
ﾊｧ…ﾊｧ…ﾊｧ…
ヤベッ（小声）
あ、こんにちは。
あぁ、こんにちは！
視聴者）ありがとうございます
ありがとうございますっ！
やべ、超太ってるはずかしっ！
気を付けてね
（奥から黄色い声援）
あーーー！！あぶねぇあぶねぇ（笑）
バイバイ･･･
はぁ･･･はぁ･･･
（子どものはしゃぐ声）
あぁら、こんにちは、こんにちは！
チーズッ！
･･･ちょっと何枚か（小声）
視聴者）はい！
視聴者）（笑）
（上がりまくる息）
うし、帰るか！
＜先ほどと同じBGM＞
もう無理だえあーーー！！！
（上がる息）
はい、というわけで
400ｍくらい走ったんですけど
もう、400で多分、、無理です。
心臓が痛いし（笑）
じゃあ最後体重量りましょう！
＜ノロマなBGM？＞
うあっ･･･
･･･ヤバい！ヤバい！！
汗ヤバい汗ヤバい！！
もうびっしゃりびっしゃりびっしゃり！！
こんなに！？ってくらい汗･･･
え、服やっばあ！！
こんなにかいてたんだ実は！！
これ絞ったら出てきますよ
あ、マジだ！！
あ、待って（笑） やば！！！！！
うそだ！！
どんだけ汗かいてんの！？
＜険しいBGM＞
気になる体重です！
うわっ･･･
約1kg減ったアアアア！
ｻｳｳﾅｻｳｳﾅｻｳｳﾅｻｳｳﾅ
ｻｰｻｻｻｻｳﾅｰｽｽｽｽｰｽｽｽｽｰﾂｰ
ｷﾃﾊｼｰｯﾀｰﾗｰ
ﾔｾﾙｶｰﾅｰｱﾚﾕｳﾃｰｰ
ﾔｾﾃﾅｲ!!!!!!!!!!!!
By:MOYASHI FACTORY